welcome back let's check back in with
rocky she's live at the american pool
players association championships and i
hear her pool stick is chalked and she's
cleaning tables rocky how you doing out
there she's ready
hey you youtube listen things are
getting real heated with myself and dr q
my coach here so tell us tell us what
we're doing dr q okay we're going to
make this really simple rocky we're
going to take the cube out some people
don't really need a cue stick you got
two balls just side arm and the balls go
right in the pocket no problem i'm gonna
do that yeah well actually you're gonna
do something much harder rocky we're not
gonna mess around with the easy stuff
okay okay what you're gonna have you do
is you're actually gonna shoot six balls
and it's gonna be phenomenal and nobody
in the world has ever missed this shot
okay so where do you think those are
going to go side pockets right
those are going to go in the corners
these are going to go on the side
trust me
aim at the big chalk rocky dead center
okay in the center follow straight to
the chalk and hit it firm fall straight
through and hit it
side pockets got it did you get it
did you get the side pockets that was
the important part okay now i see that
hey you did you see it it was awesome
okay and i want to explain dr q is a
billiard hall of famer and i heard that
that is like the harlem globetrotter
pool so they call you a pool truck or
table trotter right table trotter that's
it how long you been playing i've been
playing uh since about 10 minutes ago it
was awesome no i've been playing for 62
years wow and i have over 2 000 shots
and i understand you want to see a
really cool shot yeah we want to see it
from from dr king so i'm going to show
you something 30 seconds i got no
problem this is going to be a really
flashy shot that's impossible to miss
are you ready this we're gonna make the
pockets a little bit bigger like this
the pockets are a little bit bigger get
ready they're gonna come down we're
gonna do a countdown
15 balls in that pocket with big pockets
there we go 15 balls get ready to watch
it awesome like this one two three
four
five six seven eight
nine
ten eleven twelve thirteen fourteen
fifteen without a scratch look at there
no scratch
really quick before we go just tell
people whoever is out there they have
aspiration to be a professional pool
player what's your best advice first of
all join the apa right get involved in
competition learn your mechanics well
discipline your brain to discipline
practice and then the main thing is have
fun it's from the heart into the brain
having fun without that it's not worth
it you gotta have that fun of the game
that's the most important thing
and a cool name dr q there you go
thank you rocky thank you dr q that was
awesome that was great stuff